[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday May 3rd
no it's not it's May 2nd am I ever gonna
get that right I'm sitting in front of
different books because change is good
good work with the song in fact Hank you
did such a good job with the song that I
can't help but think that maybe you
could write one song every two weeks for
the rest of the project say every time
you have to do a Wednesday that would be
fun and also easy and by easy I mean you
know for me Hank thanks also for
standing in that line to get neil gaiman
to say hi to me neil gaiman signed more
books on that day in Helena Montana than
I've signed in my entire career I gotta
start writing about Neil Gaiman stuff
and speaking of books there's big news
out of the young adult literature world
Brotherhood 2.0 fan and future secret
sister Maureen Johnson has just had a
book banned in Oklahoma tank the book in
question is called the Bermudez triangle
I don't want to do it I don't want to do
it I don't want to do it in your pants
ah feels so good when you let it out the
Bermudez triangle in your pants Hank the
fact that the Bermudez triangle is funny
when you add in your pants is literally
the dirtiest thing about the book there
is nothing in it that's inappropriate
for teen readers for that matter there's
not really anything in it that's
inappropriate for like 10 year olds Hank
one of the biggest problems with book
banning isn't even the books that get
banned if the books that don't get
banned because they never get into
libraries in the first place because
people are scared that they're going to
get banned part of the reason we have to
fight challenges is so that librarians
know that we're with them when they get
challenged the other main reason that we
have to fight challenge is because it's
absolutely ridiculous to ban the
Bermudez triangle from a high school
library when it doesn't even contain any
like dirty words or dirty scenes or
anything all it contains is gay
characters honestly Bartlesville mid
high school are you seriously going to
ban all books that contain gay
characters from your high school library
are you gonna ban Bridget Jones diary
the color purple
no exit Brideshead Revisited Angels in
America the Picture of Dorian Gray no I
don't think novel should be removed from
high school library simply because they
have homosexual characters if you agree
with me I put the email addresses of all
the people who
on the committee most of whom haven't
even read the book right there beneath
my picture
let's email them and tell them that we
won't stand for this and then Hank if
they don't email us back we can call
them on Friday I do have their phone
numbers I'll see you tomorrow